this lawsuit is basically a stake in the
heart of veritas what little was left
that people believed in with project
vertas is now completely gone because
they're attacking you yeah exactly I
mean if there are issues with what you
were doing were truly the things that
they claimed they were when they ousted
you they should have no problem with you
going and doing your own thing I I got
the feeling that it was personal like I
wasn't around you when you were going
through it but like I imagine you were
high stress and you were just like I
don't know if you were lashing out of
people or like just like making demands
and then they were like we've had enough
of them we can't take them anymore and
then they just but like are you still on
contract with Veritas no I was fired on
February 10th so they say they never
fired you
I say they did
and our lawyers say they did February
10th because if you're saying if you're
still on contract then there are clauses
usually in bylaws for 501c3s where the
board has to agree that you can make
private uh profit off of the anything
related to the the foundation but if
you're not on contract with them that's
another story